[Music]
protests against the bombardment of gaza
have been taking place in cities
across the u.s these are scenes from
washington d.c
crowds have also gathered in boston
dallas and los
angeles earlier u.s president joe biden
spoke about the conflict to both israeli
prime minister benjamin netanyahu
and the palestinian president mahmoud
abbas
oh yes president as we well isn't it i
think you've got john hendren standing
by for us
on that and uh tell us more about what
we know about these calls
well to abbas the president expressed
sympathy
at the loss of life of palestinians he
expressed concern
about the number of children who had
been killed
in these confrontations and he said
ultimately
a two-state solution is required in
order to resolve the israeli-palestinian
conflict over time that has long been
the u.s position but to netanyahu he
added a couple of different points
to both leaders he expressed concern and
demanded the stop of hamas rockets
coming out of gaza
to netanyahu the president said that
israel had the right to defend itself
um and expressed a condemnation
of hamas and the rockets and they said
of course the president
is not talking to hamas that's because
the united states does not recognize
hamas
as the leaders of gaza and of course in
gaza they're not recognizing the
palestinian authority
as their leaders so some of these
messages tend
to get lost but the president
offered his second call to netanyahu
this was his first call to mahmud abbas
which was of course a sign of respect
and there had been some concern that at
that level
the the president had not made that
contact previously anthony blinken
the secretary of state had done so and
of course the u.s defense
secretary and the british minister of
the uh i'm sorry the uh
israeli minister of defense also had a
conversation as well
so while these talks are all ongoing
um the concern among many people in the
streets of the u.s and elsewhere
is that there's not enough pressure on
the en from the united states
on israel to stop this conflict
and on on that i mean how common is it
to see solidarity protests for
palestinians taking place across the u.s
well they've happened from time to time
but this is extraordinary because you
have a
much larger muslim population in the u.s
you've got population centers here as
well
as in miami detroit has another
huge population center and i think
there's increasing sympathy for the
palestinian cause
when you consider that there are now
members of congress rashida talib
is the first palestinian american member
of congress
um you also have uh ilhan omar
another muslim american of somali
extraction
and representing um you know many
many other constituents so what you end
up having is a much
larger crowd here much more attention
and then 20 years ago
there would have been two parties
largely here in the u.s but really one
policy toward the israeli-palestinian
conflict from the u.s
government now you're hearing dissenting
voices speaking out
on the floor of congress and of course
now we've got thousands of people
marching in the street here heading to
the capitol right now
expressing their concern that in their
opinion the us is not doing enough to
pressure israel on this conflict
john hendren thank you very much indeed
people around the world have been
rallying against israel's bombardment of
gaza
this was a scene in baghdad earlier
demonstrators gathered in tahir square
to show support for palestinians in gaza
some in the crowds were seen burning
israeli flags
demonstrators also gathered for
solidarity protests in the qatari
capital
doha hundreds of protesters wave
palestinian flags
at the grand mosque in the centre of the
city
and hundreds gathered in tunisia's
capital despite a coronavirus lockdown
that was imposed recently
they're calling on arab countries to
reject normalizing ties with israel
after four did so last year
in paris police used tear gas and water
cannon against demonstrators
who defied a protest ban to rally in
support of palestinians
the city's police chief deployed more
than 4 000 officers on the streets
and closed shops where the march was
meant to start
the court had banned the protest over
fears of violence
demonstrations were allowed to go ahead
in other cities including lille and
marseille
thousands of protesters also took to the
streets in london al jazeera's paul
brennan was there
the organizers of this march in london
had hoped for between 10 and 20 000
participants
and it looks very much as though they've
achieved that goal and this is one of
more than 30 marches
taking place up and down the uk today
saturday
the point of this is anger and
solidarity
anger about the pictures that people
have been seeing on their television
screens for the past two weeks
both as the tension ramped up in
occupied east jerusalem
but also as the conflict has erupted on
the
on the gaza border now what are they
asking for what are they demanding
well they're demanding action from the
uk government that the uk government no
longer deals trade
and arms with israel and they're
essentially saying that everybody should
take note as to exactly what is
happening
in israel they're very pragmatic the
people here and i've got to say it's a
cross-section of population from very
young
to very old they know that one march
alone
is not going to solve the middle east
conflict but they say they
they can't simply do nothing they have
to express
their solidarity with those people dying
in gaza
and in the west bank there's lots more
still to come this hour